hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled recent developments in
the sars kobe 2 landscape and testing
strategies to address this constantly
evolving field this webinar is part of
the clinical diagnostics and research
event and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific for more
information about our sponsor please go
to thermofisher.com
now let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate first by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during this presentation
you can find that live chat feature
located on the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of this
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that help desk button located
at the bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker
dr monica
gandhi a senior medical director in the
genetic testing solutions at thermo
fisher scientific for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen dr gandhi welcome you may now
begin your presentation so thanks thank
you all for being here before i start i
always like to talk about these three
things one is uh we always talk about
different tests so what is the
diagnostic test
uh what is a surveillance test and
what's the screen screening test there's
always these three terminologies we use
a lot
so diagnostic test is something that we
use that is when someone presents with a
symptom uh you know is falling sick
presents to the hospital or maybe even
is suspected of of being exposed to the
virus uh so maybe in some cases of a
contract tracing
you would test these people and that's a
diagnostic test a screening test is when
you are testing when someone is is not
suspected of symptoms is you're just
going and getting yourself tested like
we took our tests when we came here
uh or you're going to and you know
getting yourself tested to before
boarding on a plane so that's what what
is called screening
and then the third part is surveillance
and surveillance is a little bit of an
interesting topic because
uh
people use surveillance in in you know
in monitoring whether it is serology
what is the prevalence incidence
uh and
for for cover it has been a little bit
interesting because we want to not only
know the prevalence and incidence but we
also know want to know what is the
variant
and what are the different strains of
the virus that are circulating in the
community at a specific given time
um so
what we have and i'm going to be talking
about uh today i'll be focusing a little
bit on surveillance which is about this
different strains and you heard probably
in the plenary session
uh talking about where we are and where
you know what might happen with the
delta and where sort of the vaccines
might play a role
and here's some of the
uh sort of concepts right we heard these
names
we read it all the time so what's the
mutation
uh what's the variant
and what's a
a lineage
so the mutation is specifically uh a
change in in the amin in the nucleic
acid in the sequence of the viral genome
that can be either a single nucleotide
deletion uh a change uh there can be a
modification or it could even be a sort
of a deletion of a larger set of
nucleotides and you'll see that uh
happen in one of the variants that
actually happened with the with the uk
variant or the 117 or the alpha variant
the variant is when you start having a
set of mutations uh that together
constitutes what is called as a variant
and then what is the lineage a lineage
is a specific branch of the descendant
of the tree of the virus and any
specific branch of that would then be
called a variant so when we talk about
these things keep this in mind as to
what i will be referring as to what is a
mutation and what is a variant or a
lineage
when it comes to how the cdc or the or
the public health organizations have
talked about this one is they've given
these
names whether it's a variant of interest
or it's a variant of concern or it's a
variant of high consequence fortunately
we don't have any variants that are of
variant of high consequence and i'll
tell you why so far we don't have any
ones that have been escalated to that
level
a variant of interest is one that we
know has sort of changed from the
original
uh
sort of sequence
of the virus uh and we've sort of we
want to keep an eye on it uh that is the
sort of the concept of variant of
interest it's also somebody some we can
also use it interchangeably by the you
by the word variant under investigation
a variant of concern on the other hand
is something that has shown a little bit
more it's a little bit more uh higher
sort of uh
risk to
whether it is going to cause severe
disease or it's going to cause
increased transmissibility uh it might
have some potential for
vaccine evasion and those are things
that we need to really be careful about
it might even might even affect the
efficacy of a diagnostic test and you'll
see some of it actually happening
in positive and negative way
and then we have the third the highest
category if you look at the severity is
the variant of high consequence
and that would mean that we really have
uh in a situation where the vaccines are
actually not doing a job or it's really
causing high severe disease where people
are falling sick
and that is something as of now as of
this presentation there is no variant in
that variant high consequence category
now this is a slide that uh that right
part of it actually i worked on it
yesterday night so what was there was
actually this is the
this is from may of 2021 right you can
see um
you know the sort of the phylogenetic
tree of the uh of the of the virus uh
and you can see obviously at the time
you had a lot of it was alpha variant
which is right you can see in the in the
orange down there and you had a little
bit of the the beta variant i like to go
in alpha beta gamma delta so the beta
variant you can see um that is that was
the one from south africa
and then you have the p1 gamma variant
from brazil and you can see the
proportion and then you had a little bit
cropping up in india at the time which
was the the b1617 which was a delta
variant
and this is september of 2021 this was
from yesterday this is from the the
outbreak in first light
and you can see what has happened
instead is is completely changed
uh you can see here now what was the
alpha
is now quite
in in the in the last scale of thing is
pretty much taken over by delta
so now you're pretty much in a matter of
months you have seen
uh the pro the the landscape completely
shift
uh you still have uh the beta which is
right here which is this uh blue dark
blue one the gamma still hanging around
and now very interesting you can see
this little thing that is actually the
the mu variant okay so these are things
that we need to keep an eye out but you
can see a completely shift and the
domination of b61617 really taking over
and because of the high transmissibility
of this of this frame
so i'll go a little bit into the details
about the strains and tell you what are
the mutations uh and and then how these
impact to the to the surveillance
testing that that is that is important
for the next part of the presentation
um so this is the first uh variant that
was actually identified in september
uh in in the uk and in december around
the christmas time we were actually
seeing some reports come in uh from the
uk
uh talking about a very interesting
finding actually uh and this was
actually identified because of
a sort of a feature
uh an observation by the by the
investigators in the uk they reached out
to us saying that hey listen we are
using your attack path assay um and we
are seeing an interesting finding where
you have three genes that are in your
assay and
one of these targets are not amplifying
is there something wrong with the essay
and you know we said
let's look at it uh we looked at it the
assay was fine
next thing you know they did the
sequencing and when they actually
sequenced they found out that actually
there was a deletion
um in that in a region which were versus
uh which is what we have we were
targeting and that had led to that
that one target to have decreased
sensitivity
and but the other two targets were fine
so you were calling them positives
but they had a little bit of an
interesting sort of a pattern
and that's how they actually identified
the uk variant and i'll talk a little
bit about what we call the azim dropper
in my next slide
but they also identified a little bit
when they did the sequencing they
identified a little bit of the different
mutations that you can see here
uh one of the ones that actually had the
highest
impact or the the relevance was the
n501y mutation and this you can see here
this is the n501 and this is actually
the receptor binding domain
of the virus and you can see the n501y
here
and it's so close to the human h2
receptor because that's the one that
actually helps bind the spike protein
to the receptor and allows the viral uh
the entry into the cells
and i just talked about the deletion uh
this is the deletion which is a 69706
uh nucleic acid
deletion um
and it actually led to this what we call
the now it is called referred to the the
terminology we use as gene target
failure and some people use the word as
gene dropout
uh and this was the reason why they even
discovered in the first place and that's
when we knew that this virus is really
kind of
shifting to a point where we are seeing
these variants and that became the first
variant of concern this was the first
variant of concern coming out of england
and that was the one that basically
quickly rapidly spread across the world
became one of the most dominant variant
and this is we're talking about uh i
would say
december january february time
at the same time different parts of the
world the virus was evolving now the
surveillance part of it people saying
okay let's look and see what is
happening in the rest of the world
the oh this is about the drop out okay
so the dropout before i go to the next
wave there's a dropout
and this is what we have a three target
design in the assay where you have the
first target on the orf one gene uh you
have the s gene which is the spike gene
and the engine and you can see this was
the one that was constantly being sort
of uh you know not present while they
were running the assay
interesting this is actually data that
is coming out much more recently from
from september and october uh sorry july
and september and you can see this is
all the edge gene dropout because this
is uh uh sorry this is the detectable
edge gene you can see that during
november and december it's sort of you
have the green bars go down and you have
the edge gene dropouts now coming in
which is the edge gene target failure
and see what is happening a little bit
as we move into april may june you can
see now uh the s gene coming back
so the edge gene coming back in the
assay was sort of uh an indicator that
okay maybe something is changing in this
virus where we are not seeing
uh the alpha variant now
and that is something that is different
and that's where they sort of identified
a little bit more in the meantime there
were reports coming out of india that
this was actually a different variant
which was the delta variant so this is
essentially that the the early rise of
delta variant in the uk which is where
you can start seeing that the assay is
back to a three gene uh assay
okay
so in in short what what i'm trying to
say is that the edge gene dropout and
the attack pad that's actually is sort
of a uh an indicator for the presence uh
for potentially the b117 variant because
it is the it's sort of it is it
correlates with the deletion of the 6970
nuclear nucleic acids
similarly what was happening
across the rest of the world we were
seeing uh reports coming out of south
africa where they saw the another
variant
uh and this was called uh the one three
five one variant and it was now it's now
called the beta variant
uh this one had a different set of
mutations uh so i talked about the
mutations and the variants so they had a
different set of mutations one of the
mutations that was there was um
in addition to the n501 so the n501y
allows it to bind to the receptor
binding domain and then allows it entry
but it had some other key mutations and
those key mutations actually are the
ones that we need to worry about
um is is this e484k mutation
and there's a for k417n mutation these
are some of the mutations because these
mutations in studies uh have been shown
to have
poor response to antibody therapy so
when they took the convalescent plasma
from patients who had recovered and did
in vitro studies actually found a poor
neutralization of these uh of these uh
of these antibodies
and which means that these people would
not be uh
responding to monoclonal antibody
therapies or even for the matter when
they get vaccinated when you have uh
you have to build up your igg and igm
levels it could mean that now you have a
virus that could potentially evade the
mechanism and actually have the
potential to cause more disease
so this is this is something that that
that i think a lot of the uh the
sort of the physicians or the public
health experts are a little bit
concerned with the growth of especially
the south african variant as as more and
more of the people we start getting
vaccinated because of the mutations it
cons it contains in the linea in the in
the in the genome
similarly in the uh you look at the the
brazilian variant which is the the p1
variant or now it's called the gamma
variant this came out of brazil uh it's
almost seen in our 80 countries uh it
has again similarly you have this n501
and e484 now it has this different
mutation called k417t
the previous one had k417n this one has
a k417t mutation at this location at the
417 location
uh again uh what the concern with the
with the p1 is that again has a high uh
binding affinity because of the n501y
to the h2 receptor but again
very interesting it has poor response to
antibody therapies similarly based on in
vitro studies uh looks like some of
these mutations can cause
uh
poor neutralization of these antibodies
from convalescent plasma
and then the big one that happened in
india which was uh in in in
you know this was uh i would say the
march march of this year march april may
where suddenly you know i showed you
that the first three that was that you
barely saw this started cases coming out
of out of india and then it just rapidly
uh
you know completely like like uh it just
exploded uh in the country
um
it it was it you know they have
different uh lin they have different
lineages uh we have it's actually called
one six one seven but there are
different sub lineages of that it's one
six one seven one two and three
um but the one that is now called the
delta variant is actually the one six
one seven two that is actually called
the delta variant it has a specific set
of mutations it has since then become
the most dominant variant in the world
and i showed you that that picture where
it is kind of pretty much taken over and
it is rapidly rising even in the us and
rest of the world as well
in addition to some of these what we
call uh sort of parent mutations that
are there uh there are some interesting
mutations uh there's a there's a word
that was used when it first came out was
the word double mutant because it had
two specific mutants mutations
uh that was of concern and these
mutations are the ones that are the ones
in vitro studies showed
a poor response to uh you know to
antibody therapies and one was the l452r
and the e484 so q now i've been talking
about e4 84k
this one is the e484q so there are
slight changes as you can see between
one lineage to the other in some of
these mutations
and then you had another one which was a
triple mutant which was in this
situation had another additional
mutation which was p681r
when you add all these mutations
together as you can see there is you
know the viruses starting to accumulate
these mutations to a point where it you
start seeing this these strains
potentially uh get to a point where they
might be either
highly transmissible or
the the worst possible situation would
be that it starts becoming resistant to
two sort of vaccines
and this is where we started really you
know looking at and saying we really
need to understand how this virus is
evolving and and find a way to do more
of the surveillance testing which is is
very key
um because
this is and and that's and we do
surveillance testing for flu all the
time we know about flu a we know about
flu b uh and that becomes part of our
vaccines
right now our vaccines that we use for
pfizer and modern or whatever jnj they
have a specific that they have a
specific sequence
that we all take
but we need to understand how this virus
is evolving because they might have an
impact on the design of the vaccines
and you can see these are some of the
mutations of concern that are there and
this is this is where you can see and
it's it's not like it is very unique to
that there are some of the
what we call uh commonalities between
the different strains
and and it's very important to
understand that this is this is the
process of the convergent evolution of
the virus
the reason why this is important because
we have to understand that the virus is
he it's going to be an endemic situation
the virus is here to stay uh we have to
know that this is this the virus is
going to evolve it will probably outlive
all of us
and at the end of the day we have to be
able to understand every year what is
happening with the virus and what is a
different strain because that strain
will
uh will determine how we
you know what to expect
uh how do we
if if at all vaccines need to be
modified
and these are some of the mutations that
are there and all of these mutations
when you look at yes you know where you
put them together from you know from a
clinical standpoint we need to
understand how it when it all comes
together what it impacts the patient but
each of these mutations when they have
done their studies
have got have shown uh you know whether
they don't respond to
neutralization with antibodies and stuff
like that so
uh very important to track these
mutations as we go
the good thing so far so obviously at
this point i've been always talking
about what are the some of the concerns
as of now and i've used the word as of
now
because i don't know what will be there
tomorrow it could be
completely different
uh the studies that show that the
vaccines that we have so far seem to
work whether it is alpha beta gamma or
the delta
the vaccines seem to be effective and i
was listening to the plenary session and
there is some early data coming out that
there might be some decreased efficacy
and that's where the real concern comes
around is do we really need to we need
to look at this data uh
and really understand whether vaccines
need to be modified at this point
because the mrna vaccine is an
interesting technology because you can
just put another sequence in there and
uh into these lipid nanoparticles and
and and get another vaccine obviously
has to go through the approval process
but this is it is easily sort of
manipulated
but at this point if you get two doses
of the vaccines uh it is uh almost the
it has a
high very good efficacy in preventing
hospitalization and disease and i use
the word hospitalization and disease
rather than infection because
vaccines do not prevent infection they
prevent wax they prevent disease and
prevent you from from getting sick
uh
but but the but the situation of of
uh going to you know falling sick and
going down hospital is much more complex
than just getting infected because it
also depends on underlying health
conditions predisposing conditions
um age all of those make a difference in
in the efficacy of the vaccine
but so far even with the delta variant
of the vaccines with two doses based on
these studies in the last studies seem
to be effective but again
things can change
because these mutations do go on
the the latest variant that we were
talking about and this is something that
i was you know i was putting this this
lights together and there was a lot of
discussion around new variant i said you
know i need to talk about mu
uh the the mu variant is it was seen in
colombia um in 2021 it's in almost 949
countries and this you know it keeps on
changing today it must have been by now
it must have been in 50 60 countries by
now already
um it it's a there's a high mutation
accumulation um
it has and all these these these you
know these mutations that i put on the
slide are the ones that are the ones of
concern you can see the n501y that seems
to be sort of one of those backbone
lineages that on which
the new variants are being emote
obviously at the first 614g that was one
of the first backbones that backbone has
stayed it has now also been the n501y
and you can see e484k is still there
k417 and is it is still there uh p61
p681r now you have p681h that is in
there now this new one shows up r 3 46 k
and all of these mutations in some ways
have shown
in any in vitro studies uh to having
some issues with or some some sort of
impact on the virus on the
neutralization of of the antibodies
so not only does it have the increased
transmissibility of alpha and delta but
also the vaccine resistance of beta and
gamma and that's where some of the
concerns have have been risen at
the public health is what's happening
with mu let's take a look at it and see
what we need do we really need are we
really looking at a a strain that is
emerging that is potentially
maybe resistant to a vaccine
so right now i put these it's still not
been escalated to a point where it is
considered as a
sort of a variant of concern but it is
right now sitting at the variant of
interest so you have these four variants
of concern which is the
uh the alpha beta gamma delta but then
you have mu sitting here and it could
very well quickly get into that and this
still and the list keeps on kind of
changing the cdc
will will change uh their sort of
variance based on what the prevalence is
right now obviously the delta is really
taking over from because of the
transmissibility fortunately the vaccine
seemed to work
so how do we do the surveillance now
that we know that the strains
are important
they will be changing how do we continue
this awareness i talked about what
surveillance what's a diagnostic test
versus what a surveillance test is so as
we look forward this is again what chris
said what is next we really need to know
and i think it is the right thing to do
is to do for public health labs to
actually keep doing a little bit more of
the surveillance
when you look at surveillance
i look at mainly as a triangle when you
look at any sort of a testing strategy
in the lab you have your standard pcr
detection which is which is used as your
go standard for diagnostic testing
when you now start looking at the at the
right sort of this side of the triangle
you start getting into that hybrid
situation of okay getting into
uh
testing slash you know surveillance
and we have a couple of technologies
that we that we that i'm going to talk
about one is you have uh you know just
we can confirm the mutation
uh and just do the mutation verification
by by specific technologies
and then you can do what we have
capillary electrophoresis which is
angular sequencing and then you can have
which i'm going to talk a little bit
more about today is the this mutation
panel and the reason i bring about the
mutation panel i had spent all this time
talking about the mutations was because
as you can see these mutations
are specific to variance and they
the set of mutations are pretty uh kind
of give that variant its own signature
so you can use that signature
and now start doing a little bit of an
interesting way to do surveillance
uh which is using this mutation panel
and the third part of which has always
been the classic sort of surveillance
conventional method which is using next
generation sequencing this is looking at
the whole sequence of the of the viral
genome uh you have uh you know you're
essentially looking at every single
nucleotide so you can detect the current
g the current the known variance as well
as something that is emerging and novel
you can also see the new variants that
are coming up and you can still do the
capillary i put this capillary as is
common to both because it's it's a
sequencing technology
so the mutation panel
uh this is an interesting sort of a
concept
uh
it's it's you know what we have right
now is each of these mutations that i
talked about whether it was the in you
know five zero one uh why
the d614g
uh 484k e484q b681r all of them are
actually individual mutations that we
have assays for that are sitting and
these are all mainly in the spike gene
and the spike gene is one of the areas
of the viral genome that is going to
constantly mutate because that is the
one that is under a lot of evolutionary
pressure from the vaccine because the
mrna vaccine is the vaccine against the
s gene it's an
mrna against the spike protein so that
puts a lot of pressure on the virus to
evolve and you can see a lot of the
mutations are happening in the in the
spike protein so we have all these
mutations and we keep on adding more
mutations the mu mutation is in there
and you have other specific genes as
well we have the orf one a gene your f
one eight g and you have specific
mutations in in there as well and you
can see this is an amplification plot
uh showing specifically for the a484k
and you can see this what you see here
in is the wild type
and the assay is a binary assay either
you see the wild type or you see the mu
the mutant and here you can see the
mutation is a clear specific separation
between
the the mutant and the wild type so if
you see the curves down
that's when you mean that that's the
wild type and then if it if it's here
it's it's a mutant so you can easily
tell which one it is
and this actually was from our
collaborator from from abc labs in
sweden we actually have a poster if you
want to stop by and see how ola is using
it in his lab for for for surveillance
the advantage of this uh sort of system
is uh you have a we have obviously this
menu keeps add we keep adding this menu
but you can adapt this menu very quickly
based on what is the prevalence of what
strains are prevalent in in your region
um and if you look at there's a website
called outbreak.info and you can go to
that webpage
and it tells you the prevalence of
strain it comes from the scripps
institute for the last 60 days in your
region
and you can basically look at the
strains and it also has a nice way of
putting in a sort of all the strains all
the kind of variants are concerned and
any other strains that you want to add
in there and it tells you all the
mutations based on that you can quickly
form a panel and you can pick from these
choose pick and choose from here and
make a panel for yourself it uses the
same pcr instrument and the same rna
that you have extracted for diagnostic
for the testing for for calling it
positive negative and basically run this
panel on the same instrument and gives
you an answer within within an hour
so it uses the same technology same
instrument only now now you're getting
surveillance information within an hour
rather than doing sequencing and again
i'll tell you how you know how you can
kind of complement sequencing uh for
surveillance
and this is what i was talking about
this is actually coming from that page
um which i use which is outbreak info
and i i just listed here i just looked
at four variants you have the alpha beta
gamma delta and this actually shows all
the mutations in there and i said okay i
just want to have a panel for my
variance of concern and i can easily
pick and choose them
and based on that classifier i can tell
you now with this specific pattern which
of the variants it is rather than doing
the entire sequencing
people have used the three mark i call
them a mock uh mock stands for mutation
of concern
so you can have a three mock classifier
you can have a four mark classifier uh
you can see here this person actually
added a local variant in there that's
ola adding its own or i think it was one
of our collaborators adding one two five
eight in there this was adding p2 in
there which is another way not p1
but then you can have just just your
four variants of concern if you want to
add mu in there you can add mu in there
the other thing you can add is how much
redundancy do you want built in your
assay so some people like at least two
assays to identify a variant some people
like three assets to identify a variant
um
so based on that you can device a panel
and run it on the same instrument
with the rna that is already there that
you extracted for for pcr regular
diagnostic testing
what do we have for sql for sequencing
from sequencing you have we have two
specific different methods one is using
uh
the uh the the next generation
sequencing this is using you know we
have the uh the the s5 the the gene
studio iron and then you also have where
you have the two the extraction and the
sequencing which is uh two separate
instruments and then you have the
integrated intake integrated genexis
sequence so that does both the
extraction and the sequencing together
now this is again will give you the
entire sequence of of the virus so you
will know every single nucleic acid that
is there
and it can go as low as 20 copies
sanger is another way to do it
you know we have uh the seek studio and
this 3500 and the 3700
and it's a cost effective way of doing
sequencing as well we have published the
protocols and the primers for sanger
sequencing specific for the s gene uh
and and you can just order those and you
can run specifics anger sequencing as
well
and these are good for confirming the
entire sequence uh just to make sure
and the reason why i say to confirm is
because you can certainly have and again
i don't want to get into the whole sort
of this is you can look at
you know i can share this slide with you
uh you know what is the pros and cons
but the most important thing you can see
is you know here you can get these
results in hours as opposed to you know
days again you can get this in one or
two days
if you have a good workflow in your lab
these are the the the instruments as you
can see um and you can and you can see
the targets here we can you know right
now put one to twenty but those actually
it's it has ex it's grown exponentially
since we added more on the menu
um
you can obviously have these uh
different
uh the entire looking at the entire
genome here
this is the workflow that that i was
talking about so if you get a positive
sample you obviously get the the rtpc
for detection for whether it is a the
the the sarco v2 positive or negative
once it is positive and you have already
reported out to your health agencies
what you do is you essentially do the
mutation verification based on these
mutation panels very quickly
and most of them are going to be the
ones that are going to be the ones that
are prevalent for in this case if you
look at it today 99 of them are going to
be the delta variant but there is still
the mutation the virus is going to
evolve you're going to see a new variant
that is going to pop up at some point
so you you can quickly run your mutation
panel
and you can run them on many more
samples rather than doing sequencing on
a few on because right now when it comes
to surveillance the the general guidance
is you know do about five percent of
random sampling with this strategy you
can actually increase the number of
samples that you're doing surveillance
for
um and you can use that
and and upload it you have your
classifier you identify your variant
um
and then if you do i don't you you do
see that this is a variant that you're
not able to classify you can now triage
that into a sequencing and now use
sequencing only when you need it
depending on how many how many how many
variants you can
then you can decide how when you really
want to use sequencing so this has been
an interesting sort of approach by a lot
of the public health labs that are that
have to do these
sort of uh strain identification to to
conserve to first of all ramp up the
number of sequencing that they are means
around the number of surveillance
or number of cases and then use your
sequencing when you need them
so that is a sort of approach uh so i
spent a lot of time talking about
surveillance
and the next thing that i wanted to talk
about
is
it's an interesting time of the year we
are in what september october and this
is when the flu season is expected last
year was an interesting i was having the
discussion over dinner yesterday you
know last week last year we did you know
we were asking the same question was are
we going to see a flu season what will
happen we use this word windemic there
was a lot of media coverage around the
word twindemic they coined this down
twindeming it never happened
and then now we are back one year later
having the same conversation where do we
go what do we expect to see so again it
is a little bit of a forward-looking
thing but again i i wanted i want to
talk about it and see you know what will
happen we will see in the next few
months but
uh let's see the detection of why it is
important
to detect both influenza and and covid
as we as we look in the next few months
so what is you know the before i go i
just want to talk a little bit about
influenza and about cobit because it is
very important to understand the the
similarities and the differences between
these two uh these two viruses so if you
look at seasonal flu it is it cause you
know it is caused by the influenza virus
in the in the northern hemisphere we we
call it in the winter months so it is
between uh october and may with a peak
during december and february
and and you know we will see between
three and 11 percent of the of the
population having symptomatic flu and
again i say the word symptomatic because
now we use the word asymptomatic and
symptomatic and it is a symptomatic that
really is is the key because these are
the ones that will fall sick and go to
the hospital
uh but even you still have 75 percent of
the people having of the infections
being asymptomatic which means they can
spread it
uh to people who are you know high risk
uh
you know with underlying health
conditions immunocompromised
whatever you you know they can be a
little bit more predisposed to it
and has a very similar it's very easily
transmitted through
uh through aerosol that we know a lot
about you know respiratory drop lets
aerosols quickly communicate it as well
interesting we look at the statistics we
have about 45 million cases up to 45
million in a bad year we'll get up to 45
million cases per year in the us so it's
not a minor number this is and this
happens every year last year was a sort
of an
anomaly abnormality some people said oh
flu is gone it's not gone it's dormant
but and so up to 45 million cases can
happen a year
it's almost up to about 800 000
you know hospitalization with 61 000
deaths in a bad flu season you can get
that one and the reason why i'm talking
about the bad flu season is because
the last year was a dormant year we
really don't know what what has happened
with the virus in the last one year so
interesting to see where we'll go in
2020 1 22.
when you look at the two different i put
this side by side because you can see
the structure of how this virus how
these two viruses are similar and
different they look very similar but
actually they are quite different
uh they're in a different class
so both are rna viruses but one is the
ortho mix of variday and one is a
coronavirus which is the coronal very
day and you can see this structure you
have
you know the the sort of the the the
capsule and then you have these
different uh proteins on it and that is
what you have the the
the two specific proteins are the
hemagglutinin and the neuroimages so
that's why we use the word h and n and
you will see this word h1n1 h3n2 these
are basically the two proteins that are
on the on the outside and with with with
sarsko v2 you have the spike protein on
the outside it doesn't have the similar
h and n but it has a spike protein
um again a little bit more you know you
have the different strains but again you
have one strain but different variants
in uh in south korea too
so this was you know when i look at the
influence let's
look at influencer a and influencer b so
influenza a uh has has these two
specific ones that are right now
predominant one which is h1n1 and h3n2
these are the two currently circulating
strains and you can see the sort of the
graph every year you would have during
the winter months they would you see a
spike and then it go back and this is
the seasonality pattern that we have and
again you see 2020 here a big miss it is
a gap
so
you know obviously it was all the public
health counter measures everybody's
indoors everyone's wearing masks
and
and
and you see a significant clear
correlation about that with with
seasonal flu but now what is missing is
what is going to happen here
with flu b uh you know it has those two
different lineages
and again why do we talk about flu a and
flu b so
on one hand we from a clinical
standpoint most of it is they're quite
similar from a presentation standpoint
they they do present with the similar
symptoms uh there is some sort of data
that says that flu b might be more
causing more severe diseases younger
children but overall the management is
quite similar and the prognosis is also
quite similar
but it is very important for for
informing vaccine design so
you know when the vaccine has to be made
it has to incorporate
the specific vari the specific
circulating strains that's why it is
very important to know which is flu a
and flu b because we if you look at the
vaccine that we get we get what is
called as a trivalent vaccine and a
quadrivalent vaccine and these vaccines
are based on this information that is
coming out of surveillance
as far as symptom is concerned when i
start putting this slide together when
you look at it it's quite similar in a
lot of ways the similarities between the
symptoms are quite similar they all come
with fever chills cough body ache
classic classic viral symptoms um you
know and most and quite a lot of people
will go to severe disease they will have
pneumonia
people with higher with or with
predisposing health conditions greater
than 65
will have severe sort of
condition will have a little bit worse
prognosis
but there are slightly some differences
which can be if you start looking and
say okay i can probably tell whether
this is covered or whether this is uh
uh this is the flu uh in the flue you
suddenly you see a little bit more of
the secondary bacterial complications
that are super added on onto the
infection
and there are you know
interesting situation where you see a
higher risk of complication in younger
children
but what we see in covet is a little bit
different right
uh
it's actually it presented with worse
outcomes in grown-ups uh the children
actually did much better
uh but you had some of these interesting
findings that we saw where where you
would see a loss of taste complete loss
of taste people would not want to eat uh
loss of smell and you had this you know
sort of a
what we call the cytokine storm where
you had
people come in with acute respiratory
distress because they would have this
buildup of il-6 and and that would cause
a lot of the what we call the
you know the edema pulmonary edema where
they would have certain breathing issues
and they would need to go on a
ventilator
and then you would also have because of
all the sort of the inflammation you
would have the blood clots and the sort
of the
situation we would go into sort of
clotting
so these are some of the slight
differences but for majority of the
people the symptoms of are quite
overlapping very difficult to tell just
based on whether you have on the
symptoms whether you have covered or flu
so as we go into
you know november december when we start
seeing patients who are going to present
with fever chills uh body ache what is
it going to be so it has so testing is
going to be important to definition and
that and the reason it is important
because management is different
right if you look at the management
right in
in mild cases most of the most of them
go on that mainly symptomatic treatments
right take rest
you know
don't you don't have to do much uh keep
yourself hydrated uh maybe a painkiller
uh antibiotic
but if you are with covid uh in in mild
more in moderate to severe cases you are
actually there is indications for
getting people on monoclonal antibody
therapy
uh you can actually give the patient's
rem deserve it it has been approved for
use
uh
in uh with patients with covet also uh
you know there's a because those
patients have a lot of cytokines storm
and they're immune this hyper immune
response people are actually indicated
for treatment with steroids so you have
rem decimate and steroids indicated in
patients with cova so that to bring that
inflammation down
and then you have some uh
immunomodulators like biocitine or
tosalyzumab where you know you can take
an il-6 inhibitor that is actually given
to bring those levels down
the treatment is independent of viral
variant at this point um like i said i
think the viral variance is more for
informing viral you know public health
countermeasures
uh you know from transmissibility
or whether from vaccine it's important
but at this point treatment seems to be
more it's not dependent on the variant
at this point
for flu uh the treatment is actually is
different so you can see that you know
antivirals if they are given within the
first 48 hours with vitamin flu
can be is effective
you can also but and you also give
antibiotics you don't give steroids
because actually steroids will suppress
the immune response and make you
more susceptible to bacterial infections
so in in flu actually steroids are
contraindicated as opposed to in kovaid
where you want to actually give steroids
to suppress the immune system so
so the management actually fundamentally
differs
whether the patient is covered positive
or whether the patient is flu positive
so the and the only way to identify that
is going to be through testing because
the presentation clinical presentation
is very similar except for a small few
different
symptoms
so when you look at the testing
recommendations that is coming out of
the cdc so when you are especially as
we're going into a season where you can
have both strains circulating
co-circulating at the same time
uh what the recommendation is to look at
especially for patients who are in the
hospital
or in nursing home residence you need to
order a test of that test for both for
flu a
for flu and covered at the same time
and for the ones that are not requiring
hospitalization that means you're sort
of people who are just you know
asymptomatic or screening uh first test
by covet because of the covet is the
sort of the more public health emergency
at this point so first test for kovitt
and then if if not i mean if you move
forward then if you're in this required
then you can test for influenza
and if you can use a multiplex asset
that is better because it's more
efficient to do it at once
and remember one thing that and this is
something we don't have data yet but
one thing that is probably it is going
to happen is
we can we should probably be expecting
to see both infections occur at the same
time
we we say one versus the other but it is
i mean it is i think it is something to
say when you have a pre underlying sort
of uh of transmission level of covet
there is going to be a
a
possibility
i don't know what the probability will
be but there's a possibility that a
patient can be co-infected with
covariate and fluid at the same time and
we don't know how those patients will
progress because and again each patient
will be different because on their
underlying conditions
if you look at where these weight how
they how they differ in their variance
you know we have this different what we
call antigenic shift and antigenic drift
for
for for flu and we have the different
variants that we have so again very
similar similar in some ways but also a
little bit different in in some respects
i said a lot about you know why these
variants are important because a lot of
that depends on the the strain
information is key on that on the
development of the vaccines so you can
see
and vaccines do work you have the flu
vaccines that we take every year
it's recommended for high-risk groups uh
it's again updated annually based on
what strains are circulating and again
uh vaccine efficacy interestingly you
know for the flu is around forty to
sixty percent
uh it has a tribal and undercover
evident vaccines
right now covet vaccines um we are at a
point where you know we have three at
least in the us we have three different
vaccines uh mrna vaccines uh it's
recommended for everyone 12 years or
older we should see at some point it
being approved for
children between 5 and 12
and then also booster doses have been
approved for high risk uh greater than
65
and civilian
severely immunocompromised patients
whether we will need uh boosters um
that's a that is something that is going
to that that sort of should happen uh at
some point uh we will see what the
decision is going to be made
so what was the impact um you can see
again like i said you can see all these
different years we see this very sp
typical sort of
seasonality pattern and then we had
nothing happening here during covet uh
we will see how this graph progresses
but
if things have opened up and we see
school children going back to school
and you know schools are a sort of a
breeding ground with children um around
around kobe uh around flu especially
so we should expect to see if things if
if we look forward that flu to come back
in some ways uh we see you know on tv we
see the games going on people are doing
in you know going to the games playing
for you know watching college football
calling you know nfl games so if people
are going back to work so if all of this
is going to
if we are going in that road and and the
economy is opening up at some point we
should expect to see a rebound of luke
but again we will see
at this point uh the vaccinations uh if
you look at it the world vaccination for
kobe is around 42
uh the us and some of the you know this
uh the rest of the world
quite a good numbers are in their 80s or
even higher
but overall vaccinations have gone up
but what that means that means that
public health countermeasures are
falling are coming down because now
people are feeling like we can get back
to some sort of a normalcy
when that happens
why would you not expect to see some of
these things that were
impacted and things went down would want
to go back up again so you can see this
what we call the stringency index you
can see them a lot of these stringency
index where shutdowns stay home
go back you know don't come to work
but you can see you can see a lot of
them shifting from sort of the dark reds
to the to the light reds or maybe even
uh even some of the yellows so which
means we are reducing those
um
sort of public countermeasure which
means that it is we should expect to see
a rebound increase in the in in flu
cases
so what are the concerns if you look at
higher activity of flu of flu is
anticipated um
we are easing our social distancing
measures and again
we are the one of the things that is
very important is there is limited data
for the strengths from the previous
season because there was no
um flu last year so again we'll have to
see how what is the likelihood of this
uh
in impact in the season
so this is again both both these
agencies basically say that you know we
strongly support the testing for for
multiplex covered and
and and flew at the same time so what do
we have at thermofisher we have the
the covid
uh the sarsko v2 flu a and flu b combo
kit this is a kit that is basically uh
using um you know use allowed for use
with the nasopharyngeal swab in the
antenna nasal swab uses an automated
sample prep with kingfisher
uh and uses the same sort of
the the instruments that have been used
for testing which are the quants studio
fives or the the abs 7500 plus dx takes
about three hours to do it
we have the eua for it
so this is how the kit is
again same
workflow you get the samples you prep it
pcr report
the limit of detection for these ones uh
for co for you have the these are the
the sort of the gce per ml uh the tci 50
i'm talking about both dcid50 and gce so
you can see what those levels are and
again these are again you know at those
levels that are
required for for you know that cause
disease as well as the the levels and
also the different strains as you can
see the h1n1 h3n2 covers all of those
ones including some other uh flu a types
as well as the major lineages and in b
and this is sort of the the the sort of
the inclusivity data that that tells you
all the the strains that it can detect
so it certainly has the h1n1 in here the
h3n2 and a little bit else
you can see also the influenza b strains
are covered by this assay
so takes care of all the different
strains
and this is the sort of the the lod for
all of those
uh when we do that when we did the
testing for the co-infections you can
see that uh that it is highly accurate
in the presence of even with
co-infection so you can see when in this
in this case we have a high flu a case
and in a low coverage you can see uh
that it can accurately detect either of
the two agents here or flu b is negative
and you have the control here ms2
similarly in a situation here with flu b
high flu b
uh low coverage fluid not detected so
these were all contrived samples again
we could not find
cases which are co-infected so these
were you have to contrive and do it uh
from a sort of a co-infected situation
we did a clinical performance where we
compared it against another test
you know shows grade uh positive
percentage agreement and negative
percentage agreement it was on the the
the the the kid that was compared
against the the coidel lyra assay um
and for the for the sars kobe two we
compared against the because the
quadrilateral is basically for the for
the influenza a and b
for the for the co-weight part of it we
compared against our our own tack path
uh kobe 19 kit and you can see that
again great percentage agreement for for
the multiplex assay
so when you look at when i and again uh
this is the wrap-up slide this is the
final slide
uh so when we i so first part of my
slide was around the surveillance part
of it and the next part is around flu uh
so so it will continue to evolve
with new variants what we don't know
what the next variance will be we're at
mu alpha beta gamma delta mu
it is going to be important as we go
forward for surveillance testing uh it's
going to be critical
uh and especially i say this word
especially in the ones that are capable
of causing disease in the vaccinated
it's not about infection it's about
disease
and again when we look at flu i think at
least you know what we what we're seeing
is with this relaxation of these public
health countermeasures i think you know
the multiplex testing is going to be
important it's good to be prepared as we
go into the flu season with these tests
so
uh
please uh you know think about how you
are planning to implement testing
strategies in your lab and and how you
want to prepare for the next few at
least for the next year in 2021 and then
2022 flow season we'll see
so thank you all for your attention